on january 1st 2021
the night county sheriff's office
rescued a kidnapping victim who had been
missing since october of
nye county sheriff's office detectives
unit began working with the las vegas
metropolitan police department missing
persons unit in october of 2020
to locate a missing adult who was
possibly kidnapped it was believed at
the time that the victim was taken to an
unknown location in pahrump by keith
holman
and kristen pfaff despite a
collaborative effort between the two
agencies the victim was not located and
the leads to the victim's location were
exhausted
on january 1st night county sheriff's
office dispatch received a phone call
from the victim's mother
she said that her daughter was messaging
her on facebook this was the first time
anyone had heard from the victim since
she went missing in las vegas in march
of 2020.
while communicating through facebook the
victim was able to describe the
residence in which she was being held
and nye county sheriff's deputies and
detectives began searching that area
detectives were eventually able to
locate the exact address and the victim
was rescued
the investigation reveals that keith
holman sexually assaulted the victim in
2018.
in march of 2020 the victim was
kidnapped by keith holman and kristen
phaf and brought to parump where she
remained concealed and confined for the
next nine months
during her confinement the victim was
forced to perform manual labor and if
she refused she was battered
the suspects frequently traveled from
las vegas to parump and would leave the
victim locked in the residence with
little food for days at a time
the building that the victim was
confined was secured with bars on the
windows and steel doors and barricades
blocking the doors
the building was surrounded by cameras
and motion detectors holmen and phaf are
wanted by the nye county sheriff's
office for the kidnapping and false
imprisonment of the victim
holmen is considered armed and dangerous
and is possibly in possession of a
handgun
you